foreign  [Music]  [Music]  it was all waiting to happen before it  happened  you could look back and follow the  breadcrumbs along the path that led to  violence  when we looked back it had been  everywhere  it's a part of our faith to forgive we  will be forced to leave the colonies if  we do not forgive these men  none of you will listen to reason we  know that we've not imagined these  attacks we know that we are rude and  terrified  hope for the unknown is good  better than hatred of the family  [Music]  or any more violence  [Music]  we have been preyed upon like animals  maybe we should respond like animals  how would you feel if in your entire  life  [Music]  it never mattered what you thought  [Music]  and we've liberated ourselves  we will have to ask ourselves Who We Are  [Music]  [Music]  thank you  [Music]